let's answer some questions from you
guys in the audience of course you know
you can send these in via any means you
want email voicemail twitter facebook
youtube what else is there super post
them to a reddit discussion forum which
you can access a david pakman.com slash
reddit re d di t first question is from
Jenny Jenny says David what's the source
of that phrase with peace and love that
you say sometimes yeah Jenny's not the
only person to ask about this so the
backstory is a few years ago former
Beatle or is it former I guess be yeah
Beatle Ringo Starr I guess once a beetle
always a beetle I don't know Ringo Starr
of Beatles Fame once posted to his
website a message saying that he was no
longer going to be signing any
autographs or signing items of any kind
and he is the one who said something
like uh I'm telling you this with peace
and love anything postmarked after X
date will not be signed it will be
thrown away don't send anything that is
it and the whole with peace and love
thing became kind of like uh he's saying
with peace and love but he's really
saying don't bug me with any more of
these BS items to sign and I just liked
it and I heard it on a few different
shows including the Howard Stern Show so
sometimes I'll say it to be perfectly
honest I don't know if when I say it I'm
saying it somewhat sarcastically or if
I'm saying it seriously but usually I
sort of will say to uh sort of try to
lighten the critique that I am issuing I
say listen with absolute and total peace
and love I think we need to go back to
the drawing board on some of these TPS
reports that you submitted or whatever
it is right that's that's where it comes
from it comes from the betta former
Beatles drummer Ringo Starr